[Applause]
swear this to me virus if you ever think
I'm failing the people
you won't conspire behind my back you
look me in the eye as you have done
today and you'll tell me how I'm failing
me I swear it my queen what's up ladies
and gentlemen welcome back for another
Game of Thrones Season 8 prediction
video today I want to continue with my
character breakdowns let's talk about
Varys and how his story will end I made
a death prediction video about Varys a
few months ago and I still stand by my
original theory but there was one thing
from the plot leak that involved Varys
and it never ended up happening at the
end of the season so I am wondering if
they cut that scene out of the episode
for a reason this could be a potential
spoiler for the next season so please
proceed with caution because it might
still happen I am sure most of you are
well aware of the entire plot leaking
last season when it first hit the
internet almost everyone assumed it was
fake but as the photo started to come
out from the various sets the plot leaks
started to become a reality
then when season 7 finally aired it was
obvious the plot was leaked from someone
on the inside of the HBO production team
because no one could have guessed what
was going to happen in every episode
there were only two things from the plot
leaked that didn't happen one of those
things was Circe's miscarriage it said
Cersei was going to wake up in a bed of
blood in her very last scene of the
season but this was cut from the episode
for whatever reason and the other thing
that didn't happen involve Varys both of
these scenes were to take place in the
season 7 finale but I am assuming they
cut both of these scenes because of how
long the episode already was there
wasn't enough time to fit all of these
scenes in according to this league Varys
is gonna have one last scene in this
season 7 finale after the dragon pit
scene was over it was gonna show Varys
and meet with one of the little birds
Varys was going to ask her some
questions about Qyburn and she would
respond by saying Qyburn gives them all
sweets or candy then Varys would say
that is good and do you know what is
better than having one good friend two
good friends if they wouldn't have cut
this scene we would have known Varys was
about to be working with the little
birds again and this could be very
important because this could lead to
Varys his death Melisandre told Varys he
was going to die in Westeros but none of
us really know why and
it has something to do with this one
scene virus is gonna have in the finale
this would have shown varus attempting
to form some new ties to King's Landing
and I am of the belief that Varys will
betray Daenerys next season and that
will cause his own demise assuming this
was a legitimate scene they took out of
the episode I want to give another
option for how Varys could possibly die
after this I will play my original
theory that I think is more likely to
happen because some of you might not
have seen it I think most of us are an
agreement that Varys will die next
season and it's also no secret that
Varys hates magic in any red priest or
priestess he meets so it's likely they
all know something about Varys that he
doesn't want to think about when Varys
was just a little boy there was a
sorcerer that cut off his genitals and
threw them in the flames and when he did
the flames turned blue in Varys heard a
voice call out from those flames this
has haunted him his entire life and I
believe whatever the voice said has
something to do with his fate whatever
was said Melisandre and kinvaras Oh
embarrass is scared of this that's how
Melisandre knows Varys will die because
she has seen it in the flames but what
is also interesting is the fact that the
flame turned blue in this game of
Thrones universe the color blue could be
associated with the great other or the
night King more specifically so perhaps
his death will have something to do with
the arrival of the night king but I also
think it has to be linked with him
betraying Daenerys in some way because
there was more than enough for shadowing
of a betrayal by Varys and I will show
some of those scenes at the end I think
there is a possibility that Varys will
abandon Daenerys and he may flee and go
back to King's Landing
when Varys arrives in Winterfell with
the rest of the party he will soon find
out that the wall has fallen and the
night King is about to be right in their
backyard with a hundred thousand White's
some Giants and a dragon when Varys
hears this he is going to be scared
shitless Varys knows he can't protect
himself if he comes face-to-face with an
enemy like this and he may already know
his death has something to do with the
other showing up since the flame did
turn blue when he heard the voice Varys
may flee the north and he may go back to
King's Landing and this could explain
why they took out the seen of him with
the little birds because they didn't
want us to know he will have friends in
the city still
they maybe saving that for a surprise or
twist but another reason Varys could
abandon Daenerys is because of
Melisandre showing up again
Melisandre said she was going to
volantis but she also said she would
return and there is a very good
possibility Melisandre returns with the
fiery hand which is a group of slave
soldiers who guard the red temple of her
lore we know Varys is scared of
Melisandre and cavora but what do you
think he would do if they show up with
the hundred thousand followers of relora
Varys would [ __ ] his pants and run he
would not want to be surrounded by that
many people he sees as evil demon
worshippers but if Varys cuts tail and
tries to abandon Daenerys in a time of
war she could see this as a betrayal and
have him killed that could also explain
why the flame turned blue because once
the night King arrived all of these
crazy events would take place that would
ultimately lead to his death and he has
known this his entire life which is why
he may try and run away from everything
but you can't outrun your own fate this
is his destiny no matter how it ends I
just wanted to throw a few more ideas
out there because I do think that seemed
what Varys and the little birds was
meant to happen but I'm not entirely
sure how it fits in with the puzzle as a
whole but now I want to play my original
theory for how I think Varys will die if
you don't mind my saying I don't think
you should return to West dress I'm not
sure you'd be safe here
I will return their Spyder one last time
m'lady I have to die in this strange
country just like you
as you can see Melisandre scared the
[ __ ] out of Eris when she said they were
both going to die in this country now
obviously everyone has to die someday
but the way Melisandre said that made it
feel a little bit more personal as if
she knew exactly how and why Varys would
die ever since this scene took place in
season 7 many people have wondered when
and how Varys would die now that
Melisandre pretty much confirmed his
death so the big question is what is
going to lead to varus's death
how will he die or what will happen that
will cause his early demise I think that
answer basically lies with Melisandre
herself or I should say the red God also
known as real or it's no secret that
Varys has had this strange connection
with the red God ever since he was a
little boy I'm sure most of you remember
the story when Varys was just a child
a sorcerer cut off his genitals root and
stem and he tossed them in the fire and
then Varys heard a voice from the flames
a voice that has haunted him for the
rest of his life he gave me a potion
that made me powerless to move or speak
yet did nothing to dull my senses with a
hooked blade he sliced me root and stem
chanting all the while he burned my
parts in a brazier the flames turned
blue and I heard a voice answer his call
whatever Varys heard in the flames
terrified him something that Varys has
never forgotten and in my opinion
whatever it was that Varys heard could
not have been anything Pleasant and I
think it may have something to do what
Varys his fate I think since the night
Varys are the voice in the flames he
knows his own destiny and it has kept
him terrified for his entire life
and it's one of the main reasons he
hates magic and any red priestess he has
ever came across just like Varys said in
that video clip with Tyrion that's why
he was so eager to help him during the
Battle of Blackwater Bay he was hoping
Stannis and Melisandre would be killed
he hates the red priestesses because he
knows one day they are going to be
playing a part in his downfall
Melisandre or even
can vara will play a role in his death I
think that was made pretty obvious after
Melisandre said he would die in this
country because she knows how he is
going to die because she will most
likely play a role in his death when she
comes back from volantis but we also
need that closure with Ken vara can vara
gave us another big clue as to how Varys
will ultimately die should I tell you
what the voice said should I tell you
the name of the one who spoke
[Music]
we serve the same queen if you're her
true friend you have nothing to fear
from me
ken vara also scared the [ __ ] out of
Eris and ever since Varys heard the
voice in the flame he has probably been
hoping and praying that it was not true
he doesn't want to believe what he heard
but kinvaras is a reminder of what
happened at night when she has varus if
he wanted to know what was said in the
flames this terrified him because his
greatest fear is coming true all of the
series of events that have taken place
in his life is leading him to his demise
and I think the voice in the flames told
Varys how he would die but he doesn't
want to believe it to be true but
conveyor is the truth that he does not
want to face he did not want her to
repeat what was said in the flames
because it's not something that he wants
to be reminded of and think about what
else can Vera said to Varys in that
scene she said they both serve the same
queen they both served in eros and if
Varys is our true friend then you have
nothing to fear from me but something is
going to happen in the final season that
makes Varys no longer Daenerys is true
friend Varys will betray her and this
will lead to his death and Melisandre
has already seen this in the flames as
well that's how she knows he's going to
die and when Melisandre comes back from
volantis
she might have conveyor with her and
this is when Varys will be exposed for
who he truly is in the end Varys says
betrayal was already set up in season 7
episode 2 at the very beginning of the
episode when him and Daenerys had their
conversation in the war room one
Dragonstone
and I swear this if you ever betrayed me
I'll burn you alive I really expect
nothing less from the mother of dragons
can Varro foreshadowed varus's betrayal
in season six in Daenerys foreshadowed
his betrayal in season seven
Littlefinger and Varys played the game
like living legends but by the end of
the series both of them will be dead
even they couldn't survive this deadly
game Varys will be heading north with
John and Daenerys to prepare for the
White Walkers but something is going to
happen that will cause Varys to turn
sides and betray Daenerys he'll bran
might even play a role in his death too
bran could possibly warn Daenerys that
she has a traitor in her camp but deep
down I think it would be Melisandre or
conveyor who will ultimately expose
Varys and he will be burned alive just
like Daenerys had promised him if he
ever betrayed her like I said at the
beginning of this video Varys has had
this connection with whirl or and fire
ever since he was a boy his story more
or less began with his genitals being
tossed in the fire and his story will
end with him being burned alive
Melisandre always said death by fire is
the purest death what I think will
happen is right before Varys is killed
we will get the big reveal and find out
what was said in the flames that night
Varys his eyes are filling up with tears
because he knows his game is over I
think it would be incredible if
Melisandre Orkin Varro whispered in his
ear exactly what he heard in the flames
when he was a boy right before he has
burned alive and we will finally get to
hear what has kept Varys terrified for
all these years and for some reason I
just have this feeling that Varys has
known all along what would eventually
happen to him that's why he was so
scared when kinvaras asked him if he
wanted to know what was said in the
flames he didn't want to know because he
didn't want to believe it would come
true but when she reminded him that the
voice in the flames was real he was
scared to death because he knew that it
was real but this is just my opinion and
I could be wrong so please comment down
below with your theory or questions or
thoughts because I would love to hear
what you have to say about this topic
[Music]
[Music]